we still don't really have big quantum
computers we have very tiny toy ones but
from being able to demonstrate
theoretically that if a new fundamental
model of computation showed off that it
would change all of our assumptions
that's yet another example of how we
have to constantly think about what an
attacker has available and if the
attackers resources all of a sudden
change that means they can do more
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen Hughes Inga you
[Music]
know those people who work behind the
scenes to make sure nothing bad happens
to you and if they're really good you
never know who they are because nothing
bad happens to you we'll meet one of
those people dr. Brian LaMacchia is a
distinguished engineer and he heads up
the security and cryptography group at
Microsoft Research it's his job to make
sure using up-to-the-minute math that
you're safe and secure online both now
and in the post quantum world to come
today dr. LaMacchia gives us an inside
look at the world of cryptography and
the number theory behind it explains
what happens when good algorithms go bad
and tells us why even though
cryptographically relevant quantum
computers are still decades away we need
to start developing quantum resistant
algorithms right now that and much more
on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
brien LaMacchia welcome to the podcast
thank you pleasure to be here
you're a distinguished engineer at
Microsoft Research and you had the
security and cryptography team here
which you've called the companies Center
of Excellence for cryptography what is
your group do what are the big questions
you're asking the big problems you're
tackling what gets you up in the morning
we are as I said the center of
cryptographic research and development
for the company we focus on the hardest
problems that the company has that
somehow involve cryptography encryption
digital signatures things like that we
started a decade ago as a little
cryptographic tools team looking for
places within the corporate research and
development group where we could add
value and we tackled security problems
and cryptographic problems for what was
then grid computing and became cloud
computing our data centers and security
problems all over the place but for the
last three years we've been focused on
this primary work on the upcoming threat
of quantum computers if they're
successful but then we also do work on
other security forms we spend a lot of
time working on the security of Internet
of Things devices and how do we make
sure that devices inside your home can't
be manipulated we also I have a member
of my team who spends a lot of time on
election security and how do you do
verified voting and how can we bring the
best in cryptographic research to end
and verifiable elections well let's do a
little bit of a level set as we start
here about the field of cryptography can
you give us a brief history sure
Photography so cryptography is the
science of data encryption and it
actually goes back to ancient times
we know that the Romans used very simple
forms of ciphers the Caesar cipher was
used to send information around and
cryptography traditionally was in the
military field
and for the longest time it was what we
call in the field symmetric key
cryptography that is if you and I wanted
to exchange secret messages we would
agree on a secret password or a
configuration of a mechanical device or
something that we used to perform
encryption and then I would use that
secret to encrypt information to you you
would get the ciphertext to the
encrypted information and you'd use that
same secret to decrypt it so we have the
same symmetric shared secret key and of
course in the 20th century cryptography
started being used more and more to
protect wireless communications right to
protect radio this is most famously was
used in world war ii by all sides to
protect radio communications and your
listeners probably all know the story of
the german enigma machine which was a
mechanical encryption device which was
broken the initial research done by
Polish mathematicians and then it moved
to Bletchley Park and the British did a
whole bunch of work under Turing and
broke the Enigma and therefore it's
learned information in secret about
encrypted communications all of that's
within the realm of the shared key model
and then there was a breakthrough for
what was called public key cryptography
and the difference in public key is each
of us who wants to communicate has a
pair of keys that are mathematically
related a private key in a public key
and one of those keys you can release to
the world so if I want to encrypt
something to you I go get your public
key and I encrypt it to your public key
but I can't decrypt it with your public
key you can decrypt with your private
key that matches mathematically and the
same is true for me and there's a
variant of that which is the digital
signature problem which is I can use a
private half to digitally sign a message
that anybody can verify it couldn't have
only come from me and we use both of
those technologies today every time you
open a secure connection in your browser
to a website and it's an HTTP connection
there
you're doing an encryption and digital
signature operation so no nefarious
characters can learn your credit card
number or the email you're typing if
you're talking to a web email
like that let's talk about algorithms
most people take them for granted and
may even be blithely unaware that
algorithms are running their lives right
now in many many ways and I bet if you
asked anyone on the street does math
have an expiration or sell-by date or
can an algorithm go bad they just look
at you like you're strange but you've
said all cryptographic algorithms we can
degrade or break over time that's
correct
talk about that okay so unlike many
other parts of computer science and
computer programming cryptographic
algorithms which are number theory at
their heart naturally degrade over time
as we learn more about how to attack
them and as we assume that our attackers
have more compute power available to
them so we great algorithms based on
security levels how much work do we
think an attacker has to put in to break
an algorithm and as we learn more over
time the security level D creds and
algorithms that we think are okay today
are not ok tomorrow and that's really
important when you're writing an
application or a security protocol or a
computer system to understand that the
algorithms you're dependent upon today
are gonna have to change and you can't
just use them for the future it doesn't
necessarily have a sell-by date on it
but we are constantly trying to predict
what an attacker can do sure and
sometimes it's just more compute power
being available and sometimes there's an
academic result that all of a sudden
changes our understanding of number
theory I guess the other thing that is
sometimes we get a prediction of when an
algorithms gonna break like we will see
a series of work done in academia where
the attacks will come along and they
will make further and further progress
until something breaks catastrophic ly
sometimes we don't get a heads-up I can
give you two stories on that if you'd
like
I was always okay I like stories and I
better listeners do okay so a
cryptographic hash function is a
function that takes any amount of input
and hashes it down to a fixed digest
size and for a long time we used one
called md5 which was invented by Ron
Rivest professor Reverse been MIT the R
and the RSA algorithm
and we all thought it was secure and in
2004 at the annual US crypto conference
professor chou-heung Wong from China got
up and demonstrated two messages that
had the same md5 hash value and you're
not supposed to ever be able to do that
and she did that and the fact that she
could do that meant that the fundamental
security property that hash function was
no longer any good and therefore we had
to move to another hash function because
that one was busted as far as we care
from a cryptographic you didn't know
that going we didn't know that going in
but we knew when we heard it that all of
a sudden we were gonna get pressed
questions of the following morning and
in fact Josh Ben hello from my team and
I we sat at the back of the room and
wrote a four-page Q&A for all the folks
back at Microsoft to understand what
this meant for our products and services
going forward hmm we transitioned to the
next hash function that we had which was
called sha-1 but sha-1 shared some
structural properties similarities with
md5 and we figured that it would only be
time until sha-1 fell and in fact in
March of last year mark Stevens at CWI
in the Netherlands demonstrated a sha-1
hash collision and now sha-1 of course
hasn't been broken the same way md5 has
talked a little bit about how you go
about attacking your own stuff well
first off we assume that everything we
do is out in the open and this is a sort
of a fundamental thing for my group now
the algorithms themselves are open and
published the code that we ship is open
source and available and from a
theoretical perspective we assume that
the attacker has access to all knowledge
about the algorithm and the code and the
construction and the only thing they
don't have access to is the secret piece
of the key ok so when we try to attack
our own algorithms we are hopefully
using the same set of information and
it's how can we deduce the secret key
without knowing it that's part of the
analysis and thinking of new techniques
and trying them out and trying to get
cost estimates for what's doable if you
have a cloud computing infrastructure at
your back and you know what would it
cost to break something of a particular
size
[Music]
well let's move on to quantum okay this
is a big topic and it's basically what
you've been talking about for quite a
while life in a post quantum world and
that's still a ways out but as they say
in the movie industry is coming to a
screen near you that's right maybe not
your screen but somebody's and also
maybe not right away but let's talk
about what quantum computing is I know
we did a podcast with Christos Rory
who's all quantum all the time and that
was her perspective I want to hear from
her cryptographers perspective what is
it how is it fundamentally or materially
different from classical computing and
why does it matter to researchers like
you Brian sure and first off I should
point out that actually Christa gave a
great explanation of this during her
podcast and oh why our teams actually
worked together we sort of dovetail with
each other but quantum computing is a
fundamentally different model of
computing and from our perspective as
cryptographers the key breakthrough and
this actually happened in 1994 and that
was when Peter shor at 18 T Bell Labs
invented a quantum factoring algorithm
that is he demonstrated that if you had
access to a big enough quantum computer
you could solve a problem in polynomial
time that is you could factor in
polynomial time which we do not know how
to do today or anything close to them
with classical computers now Peter
didn't have a quantum computer and we
still don't really have big quantum
computers we have very tiny point ones
but from being able to demonstrate
theoretically that if a new fundamental
model of computation showed up that it
would change all of our assumptions
that's yet another example of how we
have to constantly think about what an
attacker has available and if the
attackers resources all of a sudden
change that means they can do more so
from a cryptographic perspective quantum
computing is yet another model of
computation
that opens up a different line of attack
and a different set of algorithms and
for a lot of the problems that we care
about today we know that quantum
computers will make the attacks faster
and for some of the types of
cryptography we talked about there are
easy mitigations and for some of the
things we're using J there aren't and
that's sort of what the concern is
you've talked about a big enough yeah
quantum computer let's go there for a
minute what is big enough okay well for
your listeners who might be in or so we
actually had a paper that appeared at
Asia crypt last December 2017 working
with members of Krista's team on trying
to come up with precise estimates for
how many logical qubits logical quantum
bits you need for big enough and what we
mean by that is when I think about how
difficult it is to break a cryptographic
algorithm I talk about that in terms of
how big are the keys what's the security
parameter for the algorithm so if I am
typically doing RSA with two Killam keys
2048 bit public key so that is the
modulus is the product of two primes of
each of about 1024 bits how longs it
take to factor that and that is well
beyond anything we could do with sort of
all the compute power we have available
to us today but what our paper showed is
that if you had just over double that
number of quantum bits just over 4096
quantum bits available in a quantum
computer and those are logical quantum
bits that are stable you can run Shor's
algorithm on it and you can factor that
2048 bit number in polynomial time
so for this types of public key
algorithms that we are using today if
we're talking about factoring typically
your RSA keys are 2 to 4 kilobits in
size and we need double that number of
quantum bits plus a little bit extra
basically from my perspective things
don't get interesting until there's at
least a thousand logical quantum bits
around on a quantum computer and really
up to ten thousand logical quantum bits
and that is what you call a
cryptographically irrelevant quantum
computer cryptographically relevant so
in our world
if it's God say on the order of a
thousand to ten thousand logical quantum
bits and you could program it then it
becomes cryptographically relevant I'm
gonna pay attention and now you gotta
pay attention that's where things get
catastrophic for the public key
algorithms that we're using today or
things get very interesting but below
that there might be other interesting
problems you can solve in chemistry
metallurgy agriculture things like that
well what I care about is up in the
thousand to ten thousand quantum bit
range let's say quantum does make it big
and becomes cryptographically relevant
sooner than we think what's the good
news and bad news about a big
breakthrough in quantum computing in
your mind the bad news is it means a lot
of systems that we use today have to get
upgraded and that the algorithms have to
be replaced and pretty much if you know
that an adversary has access to a
cryptographically relevant quantum
computer every commonly used public key
encryption needs to be replaced
hmm the good news is we've actually got
a bunch of candidate replacements this
is work that my team is doing other
folks around the world are doing and in
fact the US government is running a
standardization activity right now to
try to pick some new quantum resistant
public key encryption and digital
signature algorithms these are classical
algorithms you don't need a quantum
computer to run them these are
algorithms that run on classical
computers your laptop my phone they can
run just like RSA and diffie-hellman and
elliptic curve today they're just based
on different hard number theory problems
for which we don't believe there is a
fast quantum solution and an important
point here is we don't have any proofs
right now that the quantum resistant
algorithms that we're all investigating
are guaranteed to be quantum resistant
what we know is that there's no known
quantum advantage it's a little bit of a
subtle point but it's important that
even for the new algorithms that we and
other people around the world are
investigating
we don't believe having a
cryptographically relevant quantum
computer gives you any advantage over
having just a cloud full of data center
servers to help you but it's different
than saying we are guaranteed that there
is no fast quantum algorithm now we
don't know yet
right well if we situate ourselves in a
post quantum world and we're dealing
with quantum resistant algorithms who
has a vested interest in developing
these and who are the players at work
here you alluded to that just now sure
what's the big picture and who's all
involved so there's who's designing them
and then who uses them and if you think
about who uses them well it's anybody
who ships an implementation of a
cryptographic library or you know inside
of an operating system or a device
anybody who's trying to open a secure
communications channel over the Internet
you need to be able to authenticate a
party at the other end and you need to
be able to establish an encrypted
channel and send encrypted information
back and forth that's just common
practice right then as more and more of
our communications are happening on the
Internet in general we want all of those
to be encrypted and private mmm so
everybody who is involved in shipping
code like that one way or the other is
gonna be a customer of quantum resistant
algorithms who's developing it it's
academic researchers and industry
researchers cryptographers around the
world my team is currently working on
four different algorithms right now and
each of them is an international
collaboration where we have researchers
from industry and academia participating
with us on each of those four and their
different sets and you know there's some
people that are working on one algorithm
with us and some on another and these
algorithms have different pros and cons
when compared some are faster than
others some have smaller key sizes than
others they have different engineering
properties yeah and it's not clear it's
a one-size-fits-all sort of thing my
guess is that when the US government
standardizes these in hopefully five
years they'll actually choose a small
handful of encryption and digital
signature algorithms for different use
cases because what you want to fit into
that smart light switch in your phone
that you don't want to be taken over by
somebody is very different than what
you're
go put into your laptop well let's talk
about that issue right there at the US
government yeah among other governments
there's a competition going on that I
would love for you to tell us about and
what it involves and what the purpose of
it is sure so in 2015
NSA for a decade had been advancing the
use of elliptic curve public key
technology as part of a suite of
commercially available algorithms that
they called suite B as opposed to suite
a which are classified algorithms that
they encouraged industry to ship to meet
the needs of the US Department of
Defense to protect up the top secret
level information NSA came out in 2015
and said by the way if you haven't
finished the move to elliptic curve
cryptography you should save your
development cycles because we're going
to tell you to move to something quantum
resistant in the not-too-distant future
that caused the u.s. National Institutes
of Standards and Technology or NIST
which is the standard setting body for
the United States government not just
DoD for all government to launch a
standardization process or a selection
process to come up with new algorithms
and NIST has led to very successful
public standardization efforts in
cryptography in the past and so NIST has
a history of running these types of
competitions and now they've launched
this competition and in fact my team is
part of for submissions of I think about
65 that made it in and are still active
although some of those have since been
broken and what happens now is we are
all approved round one candidates and
about this time next year NIST will
announce which of those move on to round
two and during this time again
everyone's trying to crypt analyze their
own and everybody else's care and to say
what they can learn about it and it's up
to NIST to whittle it down and we
believe that then there will be around
three and that again in about five years
or so they will announce some small
subsets of algorithms that will be
approved some for public key encryption
some for digital signatures to be
implemented as the standard as the
standard they will make what's called a
Phipps
a federal information processing
standard which is an official US
government standard and then what
certainly we here at Microsoft and
others have encouraged us to do is to
then take that to an international
standards organization such as ISO and
make it an international standard
because we really want whatever comes
out of this process that everyone around
the world has contributed their
intellectual horsepower to and has
analyzed you know as much as possible to
become an international standard because
you need international standards for
interoperability we want everyone to
basically agree on strong safe and
secure algorithms so the US government
standardization is a step in that
process but it's not the end of it and
this is all aiming towards a post
quantum moral that's right this is all
about getting algorithms in place so
that if and when cryptographically
relevant quantum computers become real
that we will have algorithms that we
will already have transitioned to so
let's talk about that timeline for a
second realistically I've heard from you
and others that 15 years maybe
optimistically 15 years but why the 15
year work back plan why are you working
on this now when you've got enough
problems in a cloud-based world and all
the other things that you've referred to
well so that actually is the number I
started with in 2015 and what happened
was I know yeah I I went to Christa and
her team because we had started seeing
these signals and I said okay when do
you all think that there's a reasonable
chance that we'll have a
cryptographically relevant quantum
computer and at that time they were
saying about 15 years which was 2030 so
I thought okay 2030 is a long time away
and then you start thinking about all
the things that you have to do between
now and 2030 to effectively upgrade the
internet because that's really what
you're talking about right you have to
research new algorithms you have to try
to attack them you got to start a
standardization process you've got a
prototype them you've got to do test
deployments you got to get them running
on your own infrastructure
you've got to upgrade all your customers
using your software
and then you have to turn off and
decommission the things that will be
broken and when I looked at how long it
took us as an industry to do that for
the md5 hash function after Professor
Wong's break and I look at how long it
took to do that with the sha-1 hash
function you know you had the pieces up
you need about 15 years so I didn't
think we were actually starting too soon
I think we were starting kind of right
on time and I think we're still about
right on time if that 20 30 number is
still accurate and that's good to see
the progress that's being made within
NIST but I'm still encouraging people to
try to move a little bit quicker and to
start taking our own prototypes and
start deploying in test environments to
see how flexible their software is to
handle these types of algorithms and you
can do that today so that leads us into
the concept of cryptographic agility
which we refer to earlier talk about
what that is and why it's necessary
cryptographic agility basically is an
architectural principle in your software
that where you use cryptography you do
not hard code in a dependency on one or
a small number of algorithms it's all
about making it very easy to reconfigure
your software to use something else for
a number of reasons but everywhere that
you have a dependency on a cryptographic
algorithm you want to make sure that you
can very easily reconfigure it if all of
a sudden somebody steps up and tells you
that they can break your hash function
you want to be able to quickly flip
everything over to use another hash
function and if we know that quantum
computers are coming and that we have to
prepare for the post quantum world we
want to make sure that all of our
software that currently uses public key
cryptography is designing in the ability
to use a quantum resistant algorithm
even though we may not know exactly what
that algorithm is yet or Lane they're
going to know when they're gonna need it
but we can start making sure that all
our systems have that agility today and
part of the reason that my team doesn't
just do the theoretical work what we put
out these high-performance
sometime side-channel resistant
implementations is so that we can
actually integrate them into the
commonly used security protocols today
and show how those algorithms would work
and that's why you can actually go run
some of the most common algorithms like
TLS or SSH or VPNs with our post quantum
algorithms in the mix talk about this
concept of record now break later or as
you phrased it record now exploit later
why should we be worried about somebody
getting encrypted data that there's no
way they can unencrypted right now so
this is a real worried and the fact it's
another reason why even without quantum
computers existing today you may want to
deploy post quantum right now you have
to assume that if you're sending
sensitive data over a public network
that your adversary whomever your
adversary is will record that data has
access to the public Channel that's why
you're encrypting it in the first place
but data storage is cheap recording is
cheap so if you and I are communicating
over encrypted connection we have to
assume that our mutual adversary is
recording that traffic and storing it
away for the day in the future when
quantum computers are real and the
adversary can come back and use the
quantum computer in the future to learn
about what you and I talked about on the
encrypted channel today now if we're
exchanging recipes or something that we
don't think has a lot of long-term
secret value that may not I do
ok well mine don't ok but you know but
let's say that you are a nation-state
and you're sending information that's
classified and those things typically
have I understand a 30 or 50 year or
longer time horizon a security horizon
and it's not just national government
level data let's say that you're in the
pharmaceutical industry where some of
your research is gonna have a 20 or
30-year security horizon because that's
the patent protection on the drug or
that you are in any industry where the
informations got a long security or isin
if this time in which you need the
information to be protected is longer
then when we think quantum computers are
going to show up you have to assume that
informations couldn't be recorded and
broken when an attacker has access to a
quantum computer and so your protection
horizon is truncated by the appearance
of quantum computers if you're only
using classical algorithms so if you're
trying to protect data for say 50 years
today you should be using a combination
of the best classical schemes that we
have right now and a host quantum scheme
to try to give you some protection
beyond the advent of quantum computers
that's the safest thing that's what we
call a hybrid scheme where you use the
best classical schemes that we have many
many decades of knowledge about from
studying and add in some new protection
well let's say that does scare me and I
want to have that post quantum algorithm
or the quantum resistant algorithm can I
get it yeah in fact all of these
submissions to NIST as part of the
submission everybody had to make open
source implementations available other
algorithms okay in fact your listeners
can go out to github and they can go
download all of our code and you can go
get those libraries today and start
using them and if you happen to be a
customer of open SSL a very common TLS
implementation or open SSH or Open VPN
you can run that today we even built a
nice little demonstration device we took
a little Raspberry Pi and we turned it
into a combination Wi-Fi hotspot and
post quantum VPN endpoint so I can take
that with me anywhere in the world and
it sets up a VPN to a Linux machine
running in Azure that is my other
endpoint and I can connect wirelessly to
the hotspot in my hotel room and I've
got a post quantum tunnel back to the
azure cloud and all I've got is a
Starbucks open and unsecured networks
you probably want a little bit more than
that I probably do but yeah I just hang
out with you more speaking of the things
that scare me yes you gave a talk
recently that you subtly titled how to
prepare for certain catastrophe and
that's a perfect setup for the question
I asked all my guests which is is there
anything that keeps you up at night yeah
so the thing that keeps me up at night
is that
say Krista swore and her team are going
to be successful sooner rather than
later
and by that I mean that we're gonna see
quantum computers show up more quickly
than we anticipate that the qubit
construction challenges and the scaling
problems will get solved by the very
smart people working on them faster then
we can standardize and deploy defenses
there's this arms race going on between
the quantum computing folks who are
trying to build the quantum computers
and the post quantum cryptographers
trying to make sure the defenses are out
there before the quantum computing
people are successful that's what keeps
me up at night but it's a good problem
to have how'd you wind up doing
cryptography research what was your path
to MSR it started as an undergrad at MIT
I was a co-op student at 18 T Bell Labs
and during my junior year I took a
undergraduate class in cryptography from
Professor Shafi goldwasser who is now a
Turing Award winner for her work with
Sylvia McCauley and cryptography and
cryptography is this weird area of
computer science that is taking some of
the purest mathematics and number theory
and applying it to real-world practical
privacy and security problems and that
was my jam and at the end of the class I
asked Sophie if she could recommend some
people at Bell Labs who were doing
cryptography for my next summer
assignment and I was fortunate that she
pointed me to Andrew at Liz NGO who was
turned out to be my mentor for my
master's thesis and I did a couple
summers and a master's thesis at Bell
Labs in breaking what were then called
knapsack cryptosystems which are no
longer used because we've pretty much
broken them completely but they were a
type of public key cryptosystem that was
being studied at the time and that led
to graduate school actually my PhD was
in artificial intelligence and I went
back to Bell Labs because they were
looking for computer scientists with an
economic legal or social bent
look at public policy computer science
research hmm but the work I was doing
was interesting to Microsoft and I got
recruited out into the product teams and
then got recruited into a group to
become a cryptographic architect for
some work we were doing on trusted
computing very early on and in 2005 I
ended up over in corporate R&D working
on this little what I'd call a security
SWAT team basically for one of our
former CTO s and in 2009 we got
reorganized into Microsoft research into
this new applied division and that's
still kind of where I am and I have a
mix of researchers and engineers you
know developers program managers on my
team and everything that we do is both
about furthering the academic field as
well as putting open-source
implementations of our algorithms and
protocols out for everyone else to use
right well and that's a beautiful segue
too as we close give some parting advice
to researchers who are listening to this
podcast potential researchers what might
be on the horizon for them that you
think would be good hard problems to
work on from your perspective in the
sort of math intensive side of computer
science research well here's the easy
softball one if there's people out there
that are interested encrypt analysis
there are 60 targets very easy targets
in the NIST competition for people to go
do cryptanalytic work because all of
these algorithms are under consideration
and the more we know about something the
better one of the reasons I would not
recommend that we just solely move to
only post quantum algorithms today is
that none of these algorithms have been
studied as long as say RSA and elliptic
curve based things so that's why I
actually think for the first about
decade of deployment we're gonna do
hybrid schemes where we'll use both that
probably means you end up digitally
signing things with two keys one
classical and one post quantum so
there's a lot of cryptanalytic work
there I think we're still learning about
leakage ways in which our
implementations on software and hardware
leak information that makes it easy to
break you're not breaking the
mathematics you're effectively bypassing
the mathematics by in
furring bits of a secret key through
physical properties of the device and we
have to use physical devices to work on
this and that's a very rich area another
area that we're starting to a little bit
of work on but I think held a lot of
promise is in formally verified
implementations and I think that's a
very rich area to doing work on within
the cryptographic application space so
there's a lot of still fruitful areas of
exploration and research oh absolutely
my team did some work back in 2008 and
2009 on distributed key management and
that's for how do you share secrets
securely among say every machine in
every rack in a data center without
having somebody plug a USB device and
every machine manually and there's some
non-trivial problems in that space key
management of cryptographic keys is a
very important problem and it doesn't
tend to get as much attention as it
shouldn't I think that's another
fruitful space I have to ask you one
more question sure how do you manage
your passwords perfectly fine question
I have a couple of what I consider very
high value passwords which are all in my
head for all the typical website logins
I use a password manager so that plugs
into the browser and then that is
combined with a master password that
unlocks that vault and a physical device
that I plug in so I do two-factor
authentication and everybody should
Brian LaMacchia thank you for talking to
us today it's been really really
interesting been my pleasure thank you
very much for having me
to learn more about dr. Brian LaMacchia
and how Microsoft is working to ensure
online security and privacy in a post
quantum future visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]